I started cooking from scratch using nutrient dense,
nourishing, local and in season ingredients six years ago
while I was pregnant with my little Angel, Olympia.
Every year I look forward to the massive peach harvest
I get from the tree I planted four years ago.
I'm always looking for creative,
healthy ways to use my homegrown peaches.
Making food from scratch has quite literally changed my life,
benefiting from more energy,
passion, unity and connection to the land.
Freshly milled whole grain flour,
a caramel sauce of water, coconut sugar and butter.
I sift my flour for a lighter crumb
and grate in some whole nutmeg that offers a more pungent flavor.
Fresh caramel drizzled over my tree
ripened peach slices will be the top of the cake.
Then cream together sourdough,
discard butter, coconut sugar and three pasture eggs for my chickens.
Using a hand mixer,
this lightly sweetened batter is layered using a cookie scoop
and I bake the upside down peach cake
at 350 degrees degrees Fahrenheit
for about 30 minutes until golden and set.
The most exciting part is carefully dumping the cake
and slowly releasing the cake pan from the perfectly shaped cake.